Amid high inflation and rising housing costs,...
…it's not just young people looking for roommates.
Some Americans in their sixties and seventies are turning to home sharing.
Our economics correspondent, Paul Solman, has the story...
…about a growing number of baby boomers who are considering becoming "boommates."
Going to get some sunflower seeds.
There.
For years, Becky Miller, age 72, had only one companion.
There you go.
Maxi, a green cheeked conure.
That's Mama's Maxi bird.
But Maxi doesn't pay rent.
And Miller, a retired receptionist, was having trouble making ends meet.
I'm single, so I wasn't able to put a lot into my IRA.
So, I depleted it.
My mortgage and my HOA fees were over half of my income,...
...so I decided, for financial reasons, to get a roommate.
64 year old divorcee, Marlene Mears, moved into Miller's Longman, Colorado home...
…a year and a half ago.
I like saving money.
I like having another person to talk to, to have a relationship with.
It's nice to have some companionship when you're at home.